[Music]
she's got me saying sugar pie honey
Tim McGraw and post Malone take on stage
tumbles I didn't have any trouble at all
the country star's fall went down at an
Arizona concert as Tim walked to the
edge of the stages catwalk and kneeled
he lost his balance
got me ain't your
friend should be darn and indeed yeah
luckily for Tim his security guards were
quickly able to help as for how the
singer is doing now well his rep tells
E.T he's doing just fine
[Music]
what I've realized is put myself in a
better position physically and mentally
gives me the opportunity to get back up
quicker and and you've heard it a
million times life's not about the
failures that you have it's about how
you react to those failures and the way
you react to those spinners or what
propels you full now post Malone's full
was a little scarier while performing
his hit single circles at the St Louis
stop of his 12-carat tour he fell in
what appeared to be a hole in the middle
of the stage
[Music]
clearly in pain as he rolls around the
stage while medical personnel surround
him but he bounces back After exiting
the stage for a quick break check out
postie enjoying his beer and continuing
his scent like I'm here to make music on
Sunday the musician shared an update
with his fans revealing on Twitter he
went to the hospital and explained what
happened but whenever we do the acoustic
part of the show
uh the guitars and the guitar stand and
it goes down
and um
there's this hole so I go around there
and they turn the corner and bust my
um
winning me pretty good got me
pretty good and we just got back from
the hospital
um
and everything's good everything's good
they gave me some some pain meds and
everything so and we can keep kicking on
the tour
[Music]